hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to evolve
a poorly animated poorly written and
just downright poor animated shows that
came out of the 1980s this was one of
them the Super Mario Brothers Super Show
this is probably one of the strangest
cartoon shows that ever came out of our
generation and considering what we grew
up with that's saying a lot at the time
Super Mario Brothers was everywhere
scoring it big with two hit games on the
original NES so the appropriately named
DIC entertainment thought hey we can
profit from this - let's make a show
about these world-famous games and see
if we can come up with something truly
ridiculous and embarrassing they did and
boy was it not only stupid it was weird
weird weird now I know what you're
thinking how can a show based off the
two Italian plumbers in a land of
mushrooms who spit fire from flowers and
spend most of their time kicking turtle
shells possibly be strange well it is
mostly because when you get down to it
Mario Brothers had no story it's just
your basic hero rescues princess from
Dragons scenario nothing else so how can
you possibly Center an entire animated
series around that the short answer is
they don't the long answer well let's
take a look hey Paesanos it's the Super
Mario Brothers Super Show well at least
they have the original video games so
Kenny as I like to try to modernize it
with like some retarded rap or something
with the Mario Brothers and Plumbing's
okay you know I got a way to keep my
fucking mouth shut so the show actually
starts off with a live-action portion
with Danny Wells as Luigi and
professional wrestler captain Lou albano
and Mario okay that's kind of cool they
would often get incredible guest stars
on like Dracula Inspector Gadget and
even Elvis Wow they managed to get Elvis
they mostly sat around telling lame
jokes hoping the kids don't a lot of
company head of humor yet you must be
mud
you must be Louise your Leste kidding
this place is a boat and if you think
that piece of horrible puked-up writing
is bad wait till you see the cartoon the
anime portion stars your essential
characters Mario Luigi Princess
Toadstool and toad you know the little
bastard who we said our princess is in
another castle I wonder if he's as
annoying in the show as he is in the
game tell you you were nope he's far
more annoying I mean they really
couldn't find another voice for this guy
it sounds like Jay Leno's mentally
deficient cousin what a shitload of
shroom give him some credit though they
actually did get a woman to do the
princesses voice instead of whoever the
hell they got to do in the games
why is it I always see like a fat
middle-aged balding man doing that voice
is so creepy
while we're on the subject is it me or
just luigi sound an awful lot like
george carlin on this show I know I'm
gonna regret this um a vegetable
manicotti now say the seven words you
can't say on TV shit piss fuck cunt
cocksucker motherfucker tits fart turd
and twat and then of course there's
Bowser who they always call King Koopa
for some reason I never got that
well they just call Bowser or even the
artist formerly known as Bowser just
something I'm used to call you a bow sir
so anyway you're probably wondering
what's the story of the show boy is that
the million dollar question I say that
because the story keeps changing it's
never the same scenario sometimes
they're in the jungle sometimes they're
in the future sometimes they're in space
the fact is they didn't have any
original ideas of their own so they just
decide to rip off everybody else so you
get really lame titles like toad
warriors dark Koopa and Raiders of the
Lost mushroom haha and in every episode
Koopa would be different and one he's a
punk leader and another he's a robot in
this one I don't know what the hell he
is
vibrator maybe not all these characters
are totally flat have no personality but
trust me when I say that's not the worst
part
like let's talk about the setting in the
game everything takes place in the
Mushroom Kingdom
here good god I came to tell you how
ridiculous these settings are they live
in idiotic worlds like spy land or
jungle land or Robo land or even
stinking Carl and they have a Carl and
you can't just add the word land to
something expect it to be a fully
developed three-dimensional world like
hey I got an idea
let's all go the Puntland and after that
maybe we can spend time in table tennis
land or how about we drop by that
British guy who always seems to be in
everything but you never really take the
time to figure out what his name is land
hate it doesn't work so okay there's
nothing wrong with a little satire as
long as it's written well but I actually
think they went out of their way to make
sure this was written badly this humor
is so lame it predates half a dinosaurs
their fighting in the show I mean listen
to some of this dialogue holy
heroic May the pasta be with you nunya
lasagna loving life so long spaghetti
suckers I'm gonna make them we are you
try it meatball kilometers calamari
pasta jobs nothing but fucking pasta
jokes why cuz they're Italian
yeah is that stereotypical at all
speaking of pasta where's that lunch you
promised hey cuz we're Italian oh we
know about this lasagna comedic ly large
mustaches it meet the ball so if pasta
puns is in your cup of ragout don't
worry there's plenty of other stuff that
doesn't make sense like the animation
this stuff makes hanna-barbera look like
Hayao Miyazaki I mean the original video
games had better animation than this
half the time it doesn't even add up
like look at the scene where they throw
a bomb at this guy he's so afraid that
he actually jumps off with the bomb why
was he a kamikaze coupon it makes no
sense here's another great scene see if
you can spot the flaw here how much
longer until my bird o ray destroys the
space mushrooms planet 16 minutes ago
what you said 16 minutes literally as
the clock is showing four minutes and 25
seconds what the hell are they even
trying but he was my favorite they come
across a character called Indiana Joe
get in they move the end in the ass a
becomes a totally different name
she is satire so he comes in with a hat
the width and everything but look they
forgot to animate his face how cheap are
these bastards they couldn't even
animate facial features and they never
explain why you're just supposed to
accept the fact that he looks like that
no questions asked how hard can it be to
put a face on a person anyone can do it
I can do it watch face you fucking bum
all but wait it gets even more chaotic
just watch a few of these scenes and see
if you can make a lick of sense out of
them that was more fun than getting
crushed down too soon okay I don't wanna
know what you do Friday nights
why was the snake shooting bullets is he
flying a garbage can
hiya Belle let's go ago I'm so confused
why does he want to take your spaghetti
sauce why would anyone want to take your
spaghetti sauce and there's the Getty
it's not a valuable resource that's it
I'm done I can't taking this show makes
no sense chopping something out I don't
care just anything anything has nothing
to do with this oh yes I almost forgot
every Friday the Super Show would
replace the Mario cartoon with a Legend
of Zelda cartoon and even though it
wasn't as bad as the Mario stuff don't
still prayed and wretched I mean you
watch the opening it looks cool it's big
and epic until really excuse me princess
that's the best 86 out catchphrase that
you can come up with well if we're gonna
go this route why not exploit this shit
out of it I mean there's plenty of other
phrases you could have used like what
you talking about Zelda or maybe a more
obscure to the moon your artists or how
about the always classic always
endearing God no Mac Briggs as hot
advanced I mean just if you want to make
it more subtle for all its problems
Elvin does at least have a grounded
story tell them link are guarding the
Triforce of wisdom while the evil wizard
Ganon is constantly trying to steal it
from them trying to combine it with the
Triforce of power
whoever gets both triforces will rule
the kingdom of hyrule for it now this is
an adventure I can get behind exciting
stories dripping action and tough
nail-biting dilemmas that will keep you
on the edge of your seat like the crew
building my father's waterpark was
attacked by monsters got any ideas okay
top my Nintendo games boom oh it's funny
because with Mario you never knew what
to expect
what Zelda you always knew what you were
gonna get for example lake always tries
to get to first base with Zelda
kiss me kiss me kiss me kiss me kiss me
Jesus he's mourning the Pepe LePew
whether I'm awake or asleep you're the
girl of my dreams
that's the savviest line I've ever heard
that's nothing wait till you hear my
posture related humor Gannon always sits
and plots like Skeletor his drunken
mother-in-law those pieces of the drive
are sweet
why okay what's up a patella for a dink
a sec is that really necessary
why
what was the point I know I may not
associate ATD attention teleportation
disorder
and of course link always says princess
why because Zelda and link are always
bickering I would sleep walking walking
stop sitting down on the job banks piece
I guess you'll have to do why me
but you stop doing that now what good
boy
when did this run to the mad about you a
fantasies yo dirty ah
come on Princess Zelda she adventure
swords and flame and trying to figure
out who left the toilet seat up the
other night well I had to admit I liked
the fact of Zelda is an active character
not just a pretty damsel waiting to be
rescued I think she's actually more
managed than lay kids I mean look at
this she's always saving the day always
planning the strategies and even pushing
her loved ones out of the way so she can
focus on her work back off lady we
totally own that I also like the fact
that she actually does have a king for a
father so she's not just taking the
princess trademark because it sounds
pretty perfectly natural for them to
defend it eh
whoa what the hell is the King on look
at this eyes listen to his voice I think
I know why they call this land Hyrule
because it's always ruled by a high K
well excuse me princess it's interesting
because link is often considered one of
the keenest central video game fantasy
heroes but here he's a wisecracking
jackass kind of like a medieval wheeler
from Captain Planet I'm some sort of
cut-rate superhero you call for a hero
princess what's that supposed to mean
well excuse me princess
I'm just gonna keep saying this till
somebody makes a t-shirt out of it so
most of the time they just go to Ganon's
fortress at Castle Grayskull where they
try to steal his Triforce away while
Ganon often goes to their castle to try
to steal they're trying to force away
two saps one
for your history Ganon I know I went it
in the instruction book speaking of
which what's in there which only three
triforces I mean that's why it's called
the Triforce right because there's three
of them they come together as one so
where's the other one if it's not here
is it lost in the mystical enchanted
realms of East Orange New Jersey or
maybe in the outer regions of fantasy
and reality known as Disney's Magic
Kingdom or maybe it's in pot land I
don't know I guess it doesn't matter I'm
gonna say that the Triforce itself is
kind of strange it can actually talk and
predict the future in rhyme no less to
find your father royal dodo you must
search beneath the water it's like one
of those triangles you find in the magic
8-balls Ganon's got links Chris sword
now how can we stop him
oh dude the Triforce is not a balloon
show some respect
well excuse me princess and you shut the
hell up you metrosexual wannabe I think
if I had to pick one of my favorite
episodes one of them would have to be
the waterpark adventure because it makes
no sense you have all these demons and
creatures that you could be fighting and
what's the biggest problem
my royal waterpark should be completed
soon oh I especially like the scene
where the animators forgot to animate
the creatures claws in this scene look
you can even see what they're supposed
to be
oh yeah we're the best animators in town
just don't ask us to draw creature claws
or faces no we're not good at either of
those we keep forgetting to put them in
look at this the bubbles aren't even
moving in the background do you think
they just stopped to watch the show so
in the end what was causing all that
ruckus in the waterpark radar waterpark
was hooked into the ferry water supply
and the fairy king here got worried oh
oh oh what a misunderstanding I'm so
glad this mediocre and unimpressive
problem was resolved next week they're
gonna find out why late Vickie bad
course has a squeak in it I think the
other episode I'm like is a lonely soul
was removed from his body so he has to
tell Zelda how to defend herself and use
his weapons which of course makes no
sense she's the one who's doing all the
work to begin with
why does she suddenly need instruction
you swing that sword like
girl you know the whole roll reverse
okay doesn't really work if you already
reverse the roles to begin with we'll
excuse
me princess so even with his soul
removed from his body and on the brink
of eternal slumber if do you think that
gets any respect from our highness say I
wonder why you're the only one that
could see me just my bad luck I guess
you know what why why do you hate me so
much he's defending all of humanity just
not good enough for you your royal piece
of cocktease ha let'splay you would have
with my laser sword you no-good sack of
bitch fuck you well excuse me princess
or you could just go with that
either way the cartoon blows especially
because the Zelda games have gotten a
big reputation recently becoming kind of
like the lord of the rings of video
games so people really seem to take it
seriously and really hate this cartoon
in particular who could blame them
everything about this show is half-assed
cheesy and just downright lazy not that
we expected exactly high art but we did
in fact expect something and instead got
one hell of a silly thoroughly
unenjoyable series hell just watching
someone play the games is actually more
exciting than watching this fully
animated bullcrap not to be fair I do
think this show was probably intended
for much younger kids in mind but that's
no excuse just because something is
intended for younger kids doesn't give
you the right not to try if you're
really good at something you can make
anything entertaining and anything
plausible no matter how absurd I'm the
Nostalgia Critic now if you'll excuse me
I've never answered for pot land
continues